[Music]
[Applause]
spider-man first appears an amazing
fantasy issue number 15 in August of
1962 and was created by Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko an amazing fantasy issue
number 15 we see that a high school
student named Peter Parker is bitten by
a radioactive spider and by virtue of
this spider bite he has granted the
powers of a spider which include but are
not limited to enhanced strength speed
agility the ability to climb walls in
addition to a spider sense an ability
that alerts him to danger to his
personal body over the course of the
publication history of spider-man we see
that he becomes a formidable adversary
to several supervillains in addition to
proving himself as a premiere member of
the superhero community in the events
leading up to the Marvel Civil War
storyline we see that spider-man and
Tony Stark have formed a very close
relationship and that Tony Stark gives
spider-man an Enhanced suit which grants
and things like camouflage in addition
to appendages that grant him lies a
sight that he would normally be unable
to utilize as we progress to this Civil
War storyline we will see that Peter
Parker will play a very pivotal role
with regards to the superhuman
Registration Act both on the side of
Tony Stark as a supporter of superhuman
Registration in addition to being on the
side of Captain America as an opponent
against superhuman Registration I hope
you guys enjoyed this video and again
please keep in mind this is not designed
to be a full discussion on Spider Man
but is simply designed to either refresh
you on Spider Man or to give you a very
basic understanding of the character so
you'll understand who he is as we move
forward with our discussion in the
Marvel Civil War storyline
[Music]